Hello everybody this is Dr. Kevin Cutters and on today's Dr. Cutters live I want to talk about
growth pathways and cancer specifically the mTOR and the Keras pathways. I talked about this
a lot before but I just feel like hitting here again in some of the interventions that we could deal
with are very important. Your mTOR pathway right here is a major genetic metabolic pathway in your
body and how you heal and how you deal with cell replication and deal with cell growth.
Remember when we talk about cancer cancer is a uncontrolled cell replication but we don't
want to confuse that cell replication and cell growth and henceforth healing is a bad thing.
Of course if we cut ourselves we need to heal. Our body is constantly breaking down and
growing new cells that's part of regeneration that's part of staying healthy. It is when a cell
goes through rapid replication because something's damaged to the DNA which we've spoken about
in bacteria, fungus, chemical toxic it gets in there damages the DNA. Damages different pathways
which are supposed to cause cell death can damage pathways that proliferate cell growth,
accelerate cell growth and that's what we're talking about. That's what can cause cancer it can
lead to cancer so anything that's going to stimulate the mTOR pathway and the Keras pathways
we want to look at what we're dealing with the cancer patient. All these things up top up here
EMF cell tower, high fructose cord syrup, too much iodine in your diet,
tanky methyl groups as a supplement. We see that a lot with cancer patients coming into their
already unhigh methyl supplements. Problem with that is that can stimulate it does stimulate
mTOR and stimulates growth so think of mTOR as a major growth pathway we don't want to over stimulate
mTOR if we have cancer so is there anything wrong with taking sami and methyl B12 and methyl folate
if you don't have cancer well there can be but technically there won't be as far as growth goes
but certainly with somebody with cancer we don't want to stimulate that pathway. MSG glutamine
excess glutamine in bone broth too much animal proteins will stimulate that pathway and stimulate
mTOR pesticide exposure especially the person who has pond lung defects is going to end up
increasing mTOR and again mTH of our supplementation. Also we look on this side dairy protein drinks
plastics exposure all are going to stimulate different pathways that are going to stimulate growth
so we have to be careful of those things that's this is a real nice chart you can sit here we could
talk about it for hours but we want to move on but these are the things that we want to look at
to how can we shut down or slow down mTOR well what what just a brief look at this chart that just
eliminating or close to eliminating as many of these things on this list here can help slow down mTOR
the kind of dairy and try to eliminate by EMS and stay away from sugar stay away from iron
supplements and methyl supplements and animal proteins and and glutamine supplements and pesticides
and such is going to slow down these growth pathways everything in red here has to do with the genes
that we look at because the person with pond lung gene defects is going to end up with problems
get and DAO defects so that's all our genetic workup that we do with cancer patients
this is keras mutations we need keras as a gene keras is another growth pathway people with keras
mutations defects on that gene pathway and that's why we look at them when we look at somebody's
genetics also increase that growth pathway that we want to address so there's different drugs
that are in the market right now to help block this but we look at some different supplementations
that you could do to help block this too one of the major supplementations that can help block this
is curcumin so curcumin is the product of tumeric the active ingredient
in tumeric so using curcumin can help decrease that keras pathway here's another
slide that took from the article it was actually a lung cancer that's why I talked about DNA
damaging due to cigarette smoke components but we could say DNA damage to to any toxins within
a cell that could cause cancer or the biotoxins in a cell that cause cancer can stimulate certain
pathways that cause survival proliferation think of that why would that be you got a toxin inside
the cell well our body is trying to survive that cell is trying to survive they can stimulate
different pathways that promote cell proliferation but also stimulates the keras pathway which can cause
survival proliferation too it blocks a poptosis a poptosis is your normal program cell death
and it's again in in in your body's infinite wisdom is trying to keep the cell alive but when there's
something that's damaged the DNA of the cell and you got rapid replication within the keras pathway
is not our friend so if it's not a cancer that's in the person's body well then the keras is our friend
but what a what a cell is in rapid replication we do that you have cancer in our body keras is not
our friend keras also stimulates it up campabena we've talked a lot about that in the past that's a
inflammatory program that shuts down a poptosis and all the genes that will help stimulate
a poptosis again in order to keep the cell alive also even shuts down your p53 so keras can shut
down your p53 remember your p53 is your is your tumor suppressor pathway multiple tumor suppressor
pathways but p53 is your major tumor suppressor pathway inside the cell that means when the cell
goes into a rapid replication p53 is kicked in and when p53 is kicked in it is supposed to produce
a stimulation of cell death your capsaes pathway and that will help stimulate a poptosis and kill the
cell that is that is a cancer cell and that's why most of us don't end up with a diagnosis of cancer
because our tumor suppressor genes are doing their job so when something is damaged inside
the cell and the cell starts to go through rapid replication your tumor suppressor pathways
kick in and cause a poptosis cause cell death well if there are toxins inside the cell they can
damage the the keras pathway or if there are defects of the keras pathway it can stimulate more keras
production increase nuclear factor capa B and can help in our in this way hinder the
production our stimulation of p53 and end up promoting cell survival which is what we don't
want to do so we want p53 to kick in so again keras is not our friend in this scenario there's another great
response another great slide on the p53 pathway again the p53 pathway is your major tumor suppressor
pathway so when the p53 pathway kicks in you have growth arrest meeting that growth will stop
a poptosis will take place a poptosis is is it protects the cell from continued growth and it's
in what a poptosis is is normal program cell death so it causes the cell to go through normal
program cell death p53 also helps with DNA repair which is quite interesting but the keras pathway
is again can block this this is what this isn't gonna mess that up but this red and keras pathway
will block p53 so when there's over stimulation of that keras pathway in this case talking about
a mutation or a defect of the keras genes it causes hyper proliferation stress and it blocks the
p53 pathway so all of this is blocked if keras is hyperactive so we want to do things that are
going to slow this keras pathway and that's where you could get back to the slides back up here some
things that can decrease emtora keras are dietary considerations this list everything in yellow here
looking at all these little red boxes which are your genes that are affected keras and emtora
secondarily that you can address those things and again there are some specific nutritional
pieces like curcuminate things that you can help address those things too okay so we can talk more
about these and I do want to talk more about these individual little lectures on each one of these
that's why we have things on the EMF sin and sugar consumption and eating too much food higher
enriched foods where you have cancer and such so I'm trying to give you the big picture of this all
right thanks so much